to what extent should we trust the
visual Sensations the appreciation as a
way that Galileo did to prove things
whether scientific or spiritual well of
course one thing that we learned from
modern science which you know as well as
I do is that the 20th century science
and especially 20th century physics has
shown us that our senses lead us astray
when it comes to certain fundamental
properties of nature such as that time
is not absolute and that at the
subatomic level that particles take on a
wavy dualistic character and particle
can be in several places at once those
behaviors of nature contradict our
common experience the senses when you
get to very high speeds relative speeds
or very small sizes our senses give us
an inaccurate Intuition or understanding
of nature
thank you